lobo
longtemps alors
le fait est que l'ortie est très
pourquoi s'appelle margerie annoncé
mireille c'est comme ça
après du ruisseau c'est la sortie du lac
en fête hier qu elle arrive par là bas
si gainey
pour peu on peut on peut essayer de
gagner un quart d'heure sur le parcours
pour rejoindre
ok les parties
on s'est réfugié dans le chalet destiné
à cet effet en cas de l'intempérie et
donc on a dormi à même le sol
en tout cas au moins sur un tapis de sol
voilà la nuit était un petit peu courte
voilà mon dormir du tout je
moi j'étais content de monter j'étais
effectivement un peu déçu de décent par
contre j'ai été mais parce que j'aurais
bien je jeu comme j'ai déjà fais pas de
soucis au niveau du froid j'aurais bien
voulu passer la nuit et je veux dire
rentrer chez moi en disant mais qu à mes
copains j'ai passé là les accrocher dans
les airs va dormir dire la cccd assez
exceptionnel
j'étais super content mais je tiens
quand même à dire que je suis pas le
ronfleur en fait donc géré enflé pour
revivre comme simplement pour lui la
même expérience et tout je ne trouve pas
mais comme les foules heureusement que
chez pol aujourd'hui ce sont
je suis allé voir les trois rescapés de
l'élite suspendus
pas de bruit ça dort ce matin de bonne
heure à ma grande surprise parce que je
trouve quand même qu'il pleuvait
relativement fort
enfin deux enfin nul à mais ils ont
l'air d'avoir été protégé suffisamment
par les failles pour pas être bourget de
quoi on est bien on n'est pas là encore
même le bruit de la pluie c'était
agréable ouais c'est ça quand on a eu la
surprise hier soir nous ont bandé les
yeux quand on a envie aux le bandage
ouais c'était le fou rire est en fait
ouais ça m'aurait fait trop râler pour
pouvoir rester toute l'année déjà c'est
mystique on va se coucher on était déjà
quand même dans le noir
il faut quand même faire un petit peu
d'efforts pour pouvoir atteindre le lit
et quelques semaines on est on est
arrivés en fait dans ce magic pression
dans un autre monde
elles ont dû avoir froid ils ont dû à
mon avis avoir un petit peu peur quand
même et mon chapeau au respect respect
fait trop froid
vous avez bien dormi
je pense que si on avait eu un temps
magnifique
si j'avais pu voir par exemple des
animaux ou entendre des animaux voir la
lune les étoiles
là ça aurait vraiment été mémorable
peut-être comme ça suspendus dans les
arbres fait qu'il pleuvait c'était
humide était mitigée en fait ça a un peu
gâché le truc c'est vraiment un peu le
voir à un moment donné un peu beaucoup
et je me suis dit je vais avoir le une
buvette où tout trempé je sentais avec
ma main là déjà il était mouillée alors
j'ai sorti la couverture de survie
depuis dix ans - ça va ça va un petit
peu protégés
quand vous êtes pris dans mon esprit
c'est beaucoup juste un poids pour le
programme aujourd'hui donc je prends la
carte conditions météo un peu difficile
on va démarrer par la grosse crise
forestière
allez on y va on va pas traîner parce
qu'il faut s'attaquer froid
tout d'abord c'est juste qu'on s'arrête
un peu trop longtemps on risque de
prendre froid pour leur faire un petit
détour différents cela me fait un petit
peu mal et qu'on leur accorde pas
s'arrêter pour notre
on a de la purée de banane que frédéric
nous avait emmenés en dessert et puis la
citadelle qui fait partie du chemin des
crêtes vosgiennes encore de chaque côté
normalement devait avoir un super un
super un super regard sur eux sur sur le
sur ce qu'il y avait autour et manque de
pot du la pluie du brouillard du froid
aujourd'hui la le la météo n'est pas
favorable pour pour faire ces activités
là il pleut il fait froid et brouillard
enfin voila mais tout le monde est
heureux la preuve puisque on a rien on
chante en français c'est pas les
colonies de vacances mais presque pas
alors on va on va remballer tout
doucement terminé de séché à la balade
de cet après midi donc environ 1h30 2h
de marche
ça va être ça que vous avez dans le fond
de sac qui vous réchauffer les couches
entend la polaire machin vous mettez
tout ici est un camp des gants c'est le
moment de sortir voilà faut se dire que
l'on va perdre encore une paire de
vieilles va on va pas faire tout et
vivait à une centaine de bêtes mais
après match on monte plus on va voir
remarquons toutefois si si dans cette
direction ça des pierriers
i dans la forêt va s'arrêter et c'est là
où ça va être compliqué au niveau météo
les locaux de l'école à le fabriquer
ouvert la voie et on va se faire cette
bonne grimpette là entre deux pierres y
ait deux ans grise ce moteur jour et
pourquoi bascula il ya il est la façon
de le faire c'est un pédagogue il
plaisante avec nous ils assument allait
nous écouter il a réussi et je pense à
découvrir comment la personnalité de
chacun les voix c'est très joli mais
froid et surtout est aujourd'hui là
c'était des conditions
le ciel était bas il faisait gris il
pleuvait du vent non pas pour moi ça
approchez approchez donné
c'est
et ont séjourné dans ce jour un peu de
réconfort
merci beaucoup c'est pas ce n'est pas du
bourguignon mais on va faire du tir
quand même est une spécialité alsacienne
les vraies celles d'eads explique air
n'est pas un cépage les dettes chiker
est un assemblage de 20 on peut avoir du
muscat on peut avoir du riesling on peut
avoir du gué du rzs traminer c'est en
fonction des stocks qui restent à la fin
de l'année à chaque ligne euros qu'il
fait son assemblage et ça s'appelle et
dès ce week-end avec ce nom c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on a eu déjà dû
conditions météo qui t'est pas ça
s'empire d'honneur du dernières
nouvelles du froid demain en plus
d'aujourd'hui donc les précipitations
peu est pas plus importante
on va dire du même ordre mais une
température ressentie qui avoisine
0 degré donc nous aurons peut-être le
plaisir de voir nos premiers flocons de
neige ensemble sur les bouilles jeu pour
à cette paire est content de voir j'ai
pas le froid ou pas donc c'est joli à
voir la neige en cartes postales mais
dedans non j'aime pas trop moche frileux
comme garçons m'ont donc t'as vu
d'entrée
tu vas voir la suite tu as de quoi
prendre des calories pour affronter deux
mois d'hiver assez périlleux tarbes
oui on a deuxième là parce qu'il ya la
poche et découpé pourquoi mais vosgien
est c koi tu vas avoir le plaisir de les
coupler way
mais ça ce sont des pommes de terre et
qui porte ici dans les fermes auberges
un nom tout à fait un trône on sable ça
s'appelle d'héroïque ehpad
ces messages et bani walid on va le dire
gros il s'est cru etc et prague s'est
grillé donc en effet revenir avec de
l'oignon dans une cocotte sinon les
raquettes ouais voilà
bonjour on est debout avant oui on a
fait la fête pour amener du lait tout
frais pour le petit déjeuner donc après
la journée
elle semble déjà gagné matin pas si cet
argent dans un lieu suprise sublime ben
oui mais du mauvais temps mais c'est
l'âme de notre but il se taille sur ce
mauvais temps on fait encore notre
fromage bien à nous avec notre méthode
et nos lacs et nos folies on vit avec la
nature elle nous protège et on la
respecte
donc on attend un peu plus les gars on
va recouvrir tous ensemble à
l'inventaire ailleurs reste et on allait
casser la croûte
entre le petit déjeuner vraiment copieux
pour avoir des forces pour la journée en
appétit et bon petit déjeuner doucement
medibat chaque goutte format choisir ce
sont 20 de démouler les gars merci c'est
toutes ces odeurs qui sans trop fort
pour moi sur ce matin ça me retourne
estomac cet appétissant pour moi tout ça
c'est dommage
annonçant un chippendale
je vous donne un indice êtes prêts reste
qu à la fin de mai valait sonnera cuenta
le trading tonolito fwouedd alors là je
suis chanteur d'opéra et pourquoi vous
allez me dire pourquoi du chant d'opéra
dans la nature parce que pour moi c'est
c'est le sens d'opéra c'est un chant
tribal c'est un chant de toutes les
cellules de tous et au toute sa matière
le principe ces cinq stations ouverture
des cinq sens à chaque fois on répète le
texte la musique on met les choses
ensemble et ensuite moi je viens chanter
avec vous en fait faire une petite
vocalises pour démarrer c'est la
vocaliste de la soupe aux choux
dray connaissait savez ce que ça vous
fait travailler la diction les lèvres la
langue à vous
à cette session de travail de texte
toréador ans gars 2 en quarts à aare de
ses importants le petit gars à coma et
son jeu bien huit sont jean combattants
et sans jeu bien huit sont jean
combattants et son jeu vient 8 songeant
combattants de toréador en gare à eux
auraient adoré ado et son jeu bien hui
son jean combattants qu'un oeil noir de
regard et que l'amour tu as dans l'eau
toréador
j'aime bien chanter quand je suis dans
la nature tout seul moi je chante
franchement je chante je siffle là ça me
fait plaisir
opéra je connais pas trop ça fait
plaisir de découvrir ici on est à la
station de l'odorat on était
l'observation de prendre chacun un petit
rat mots comme ça de sapins voilà que
vous ayez chacun je vais me laisser
passer un petit quelque chose comme ça
voilà qu'arrive ou bien dans vos dents
voilà une proposition de chanteur voilà
plutôt les pieds parallèles un meilleur
équilibre et puis on va se frotter ça
dans les mains comme ça et le respirer à
pleins poumons en mettant le nez dans
les mains et en respirant dans votre
bassin en même temps elle a fait le
plusieurs fois jeu là c'est du shoot un
shooter vous c'est excellent triste et
d'un voile à un moment donné on le fait
et on va faire juste derrière comme si
nous faisions d'un gâteau d'un parfum
que vous êtes aurait on y va tous
ensemble d'actifs allez on se frotte
espèce de soupe un soulagement
malaisie on le nourrit ont cherché cette
énergie là
lâchez le sang et sentez que vous pouvez
faire vibrer vos yeux
oh
un mois
bon
oh
oh non
à toulouse
alors c'est parti on se dirige
tranquillement vers la station du goût
on va continuer à éveiller les zones
buccale qui servent à chanter grâce à
une recherche de bouc que je vais vous
proposer les prix c'est parti on y va
c'est un groupe qui est rentré dedans
tout de suite voilà il ya une envie une
curiosité et ça j'ai passé tous et tous
les groupes ce qui se passe en général
c'est qu'à la fin ça s'ouvre hélas assez
ouvert assez rapidement et avec un vrai
enthousiasme devrait voilà une vraie
chaleur une vraie envie quoi ça c'est ça
fait plaisir et c'est facile pour moi du
coup de lumière un groupe comme ça et de
partager ce que je connais
pourtant paris thoune
et encore
je réside à cet effort c'est vraiment
très très fort je sais pas ça m'a fait
quelque chose quoi déjà dans le corps
fait quand il n'est pas content il monte
dans la puissance dans les vocalises
moi ça me secoue les tripes comme disait
gérard mais en plus de ça j'ai pas le
fait qu'on se quitte après tout ce je
ressentais je ressentais déjà la
tristesse de ce à travers ce que lui
traversa à travers sa voix quoi j'étais
en carrière je chantais partout dans le
monde ne savait pas dire non
j'ai perdu ma voix à un moment donné
pour la retrouver
il a fallu que j'aille dans la nature je
suis allé dans un voyage initiatique
chez les amérindiens
c'est lurons au québec un chercheur dia
m'a accueilli et me dis ouah n'était pas
dans le moment présent et que dans les
regrets de ton passé le ténor qui était
et que dans les projets futurs redevenir
un ténor et c'est dans la carrière était
pas dans le présente avec n'était plus
dans la vie je vais trouver mes mots dit
je vais taire réapprendre à venir dans
la vie à spa de bons enceinte et par mon
gars et voilà et progressivement en
quatre mois il m'a confié une chaîne
louvre moitié loup à chaque fois je me
baladais la nature et j'ai réappris à
revenir dans le présent et où des rites
initiatiques
je suis de mieux en mer indien maurice
quoi c'est mon nom amérindien
ça veut dire le loup est petit à petit
ma voix est revenu et ma joie de vivre
aussi c'était pas la voix c'est le
baromètre de tous et casser la gueule
en attendant de trouver à l'eau aux
abords je viens me sens en convainquant
mika
voilà qu'on va terminer là c'est quoi la
le coucou coucou
non
cocoon